porque en france24 hablamos de economía
y para ello me acompaña en el estudio
nuestra periodista daniela blandón
daniela buenas noches y bienvenida vamos
a iniciar con una noticia económica
positiva las bolsas del mundo terminaron
noviembre como el mejor mes en décadas
valentina muy buenas noches le tengo una
mala y una buena la mala casi todas las
bolsas del mundo cerraron el lunes en
negativo y la buena es que en noviembre
las ganancias fueron históricas los
avances en las vacunas contra el kobe de
19 y la menor incertidumbre política en
eeuu podrían explicar estos resultados
veamos en wall street sus tres índices
principales batieron récord histórico
este mes y subieron más del 10 por
ciento el más importante down jones de
industriales- despidió su mejor mes
desde 1987 mientras tanto la ganancia
mensual para el standard and poor's y
para el nasdaq no se veía desde abril en
europa el resultado más destacable es el
de españa que cerró noviembre con la
mejor alza mensual de su historia más
del 25 por ciento y en américa latina'
de sao paulo marcó su mejor ganancia en
un mes desde marzo de 2016 y en mexico
se vio el mejor desempeño mensual en 15
años daniela y ahora nos centramos en
eeuu porque el presidente electo joe
biden confirmó su equipo económico sus
nominados si este equipo está conformado
en su mayoría por mujeres y lideradas
por un peso pesado de la economía en ese
país janet yellen de 74 años quien hasta
2014 fue presidenta de la reserva
federal así lo confirma si así lo
confirma el senado será la primera
secretaria del tesoro en 231 años de
existencia de esta entidad al lado de
jelen como secretario adjunto wali de
gemma un veterano de la rama ejecutiva y
experto en política macroeconómica y en
protección al consumidor completan este
equipo ni va a tender quien se
convertiría en la primera mujer
afrodescendiente y de origen indio en
liderar la oficina de administración y
presupuesto y cecilia a graus quien
también sería la primera
en presidir el consejo de asesores
económicos
janet yellen y su equipo tienen posturas
económicas liberales y fueron
funcionarios clave en las dos
administraciones demócratas anteriores
la de barack obama y bill clinton
bueno daniela y de eeuu pasamos a méxico
porque una noticia preocupante se han
cerrado más de 35.000 empresas por la
pandemia y valentina coparmex que es la
federació confederación patronal de
mexico visualiza este complejo panorama
como consecuencia de la crisis hay un
informe además de la compañía solo unión
que gestiona seguros de crédito que dice
que los impagos de las empresas crecerán
más de un 30 por ciento en 2020 respecto
a 2019 esto quiere decir que hoy a nueve
de cada diez empresas sus compradores no
les están pagando esa situación afecta
principalmente a las empresas que venden
no de contado sino a crédito y que están
comenzando a ver retrasos en sus pagos
daniela y por último una serie de
netflix que amenaza con causar un
conflicto diplomático yo sé que usted se
la ve
se llama the crown y rastrea los 68 años
de mandato de la reina isabel en cuatro
años de producción las cuestiones de
fidelidad histórica no habían sido un
problema hasta que llegó la cuarta
temporada esta está ambientada la muy
convulsionada década de 1980 entre los
personajes están la ex primera ministra
margaret thatcher y la difunta princesa
diana pero poco le ha gustado esto a la
corona británica pues se espera que en
los próximos días el gobierno del reino
unido- le solicite formalmente a netflix
que aclare en sus capítulos de the crow
que es una serie de ficción la familia
real británica es muy hermética
valentina de hecho la reina isabel nunca
ha hablado de su vida privada en ningún
artículo o entrevista en medios desde
que inició su reinado en 1952 muy
diferentes son el príncipe harry y su
esposa megan markel quienes se separaron
de la coreana aunque no puede referirse
a este tema porque acaban de firmar un
contrato millonario con netflix para
producir varios contenidos
daniela y vamos a finalizar este espacio
con la cifra del día son los 10 millones
de euros que italia le puso de multa a
apple por hacer falsa publicidad sobre
la resistencia del iphone al agua
escuchar en las autoridades dicen que en
la publicidad de varias referencias no
se aclaraba que esa resistencia sólo se
da en determinadas condiciones y
agregaron que no funcionan en el agua
sucia daniela gracias por toda esta
información y ustedes por continuar con
nosotros estos france24
[Música]